Okay.
Should be live here.
Let me make an announcement post and
we'll get started.
Hi, Jess.
Welcome.
So, we have a few things to look at.
yeah, so we don't really have enough
experiments yet on the baseline,
but I have um I have some cool stuff to
show you all.
Oops.
Uh, hello. Where is my
Where's my window?
Huh?
Put this in linear scale for you.
This is so
Hello. Okay. Yeah. No, the mic works.
It's just the camera. Let me just
replplug the stupid camera in. Um, but
here, let me show this first just in
case this is screwing with stuff. I
think this is just stupid Windows
machine. Bear with me today. Um, so I
don't have a full sweep on the baseline
yet that's running now. But with state
sets, we get to 54% solve rate on
difficulty 2 of Zokabon.
So this is a pretty cool result right
here. This is a pretty pretty cool
result. Um, and this is with like zero
domain specific anything, right? People
have worked on Soabon for years. So,
yeah, they have some pretty crazy chunky
models for it, but this is just straight
puffer.
Let me replug the camera and we'll see
if that's stable.
I'm probably just going to end up
redoing this whole room at some point,
but not this summer.
This is um
47 some odd experiments in.
And this is nowhere near uh the perf
that we have now. So, we'll see. The
hope is that the baseline actually does
not do particularly well,
but we're not going to wait it. We're
just going to let it see. Uh we're going
to just wait and we're just going to see
whether or not it does what we expect.
And uh we'll actually just sort of have
to think about stuff in the meantime. So
here
Thank you, Convert.
These two are like nice looking M's
though to have on the site for sure.
These are sort of smaller things I was
playing with. Not a huge deal.
I just need to reook at the way we do it
just because I'd like to get rid of
reward clipping if we can.
I could also just assert that the reward
is not out of bounds.
Free sweep breakout.
That's easy enough.
I guess the main thing in my mind,
right, it's like I have a bunch of
fairly easy things to get done and I
could just decide that, you know,
there's nothing I can do until we run
full sweeps. I'm just going to focus on
that and we'll see from there.
I would like to run a little bit of
analysis before I do that. Let me let me
try to just see if I can convince myself
of something here real quick.
Hopefully this doesn't screw up the
camera again.
I'm going to mess with my encoder.
Um, but I'm basically I'm basically
positive that it's not my encoder.
So, look at this. Right, this is
I can also scale down the the preview
window a little bit.
Just tune this a little bit and
pause the preview. Cool.
That'll be fine. So,
it does look to me like you need to have
the curriculum in order for this thing
to work. It seems quite clearly
dependent on this.
It also does seem like you need a
reasonable size state buffer.
This is the exploration decay.
So it seems very very important that you
have a high decay factor.
Uh this is the this is the exact result
that we want so far which is from the
sweep it looks like the solutions we
found are very very dependent on
curriculum.
So we essentially just need to run the
full baseline sweep and uh if it is
truly the case that we do way better
with curriculum than without that is
sufficient evidence on its own for
puffer 5.
If that ends up not being the case,
then we are just confused
and then I have to think about stuff a
bunch.
I think there's no point considering the
failure case at the moment because then
it's just going to be like I don't know,
I got to go take a long walk and think
about stuff.
Let's just assume that we're going to
get the result we expect for now and
just decide like what would we do next?
Are there meaningful changes we could
make to this algorithm?
You need to store on the order of
thousands of states
which I believe should be fine with our
algorithm. them.
Is there any reason to expect us to not
need a top K?
Let's just double check codeex real
quick.
I don't know. We'll just use this as
fuzzy lit search.
Um, I don't think there is anything, but
there's no harm in sanity checking.
I'm just thinking of like possible
problems, right? Like what could we have
as a problem from this end?
There really aren't that many things we
can like ablate. I guess whether or not
we anneal a few of the coefficients
maybe.
There's not that much to a blade,
though.
Success rate is not what we want. It's
not generic enough.
purple. Yeah. No, we're not going to
This is some random paper.
Okay.
I mean, we can look at the PLR paper
again.
Does it just keep a buffer over all the
levels though or hang on. How's this
work?
I Guess actually just like a few metrics
on what we're using for the buffer.
Maybe we could ablate.
Hang on. This is This is probably what
we want.
We're alive. Yeah, we're alive.
So,
I think actually most of what we need is
in here.
I'm kind of seeing the space of possible
algorithm changes though for um 50.
It's a pretty small constrained space.
We'll have to run a couple weeks worth
of experiments most likely. Nothing too
bad. I think Soabon is a good enough
test.
Oh yeah. So Volo um we got very nice
sweep results overnight on uh Soabon
with state sets. Everything looks very
good from the data, but we need to run a
very like we need to run a big
aggressive sweep on the baseline now. So
that's what I'm doing. Um, if the
baseline sweep fails to do anywhere near
as well as the state set one, we're
basically golden and all we have to do
is run some small ablations on the
algorithm over the next couple weeks and
then we chuck it on Inferno and
everything else and uh, core 50 is done.
This should be strictly more powerful
than PLR.
So yeah, we should expect this to be a
very large difference.
Uh yeah, I think actually the PLR paper
probably has everything that I
I hate pretty much anything that's based
on um R&D.
Yeah.
Okay. So,
let's take a look at their results with
that in mind. Now,
what was the best result of the sweep
score-wise?
Check this out.
Oops. I'm on the wrong machine, aren't
I?
So, that's better than log linear. It's
actually very close to um just standard
like linear per
on Soaban.
And it seems like it scales linearly
with um with Perf, which is basically
what you would expect
uh for this type of an algorithm
cuz essentially it's like it's just a
bunch of really hard exploration
problems
and it just takes a long time to get
lucky enough to see the solutions the
first time and that's where most of the
compute goes.
It's pretty cool though if we convert
like if we end up getting linear PF with
time. That's a major major
accomplishment.
here's uniform.
All right, here's PLR.
Wait. Train test
and then on test.
Oh,
wait. What?
Oh, I see. They I know what they did
here. I see why how they screwed this
up.
Oh, wait. Lower is better here, right?
Mean generalization gap. Dude, why would
you do this?
Why would you do this?
Wait, mean generalization gap.
The lower is better here, right?
Why would you make it so that on this
plot higher is better and on this plot
lower is better?
Why would you do this?
And wait, how does this generalization
gap
Okay, this is weird.
Wait, train test.
Oh, okay. I see.
So, on training
uniform is also up here.
So, wait, they're saying there's a big
train test gap.
Uh, that's odd. How many levels do you
have?
Oh, 1,000 levels.
Wait, where's procgen?
Do I just need to read this whole thing
again?
I guess I kind of can right now.
Y'all want to do um paper reading
session on this? This one's probably
actually worth reading cuz I think this
is the closest thing to everything that
we need.
TD error effectively estimates a level's
future learning potential. So that's an
alternative metric.
I'm basically going to read through and
I'm just going to highlight things that
I think are important for you all.
Okay. So this is uh this is state sets
to starts of levels. So the approach
already should no matter what you do be
strictly weaker than what we are doing.
Do you understand this?
So they have to start to they have to
start only at brand new fresh levels. We
get to start anywhere. So this is a
strictly weaker approach cuz they're not
assuming that they have the access to
set the state to anything.
Which means if you do have the ability,
this should be strictly weaker. And
there's good reason to expect ours to be
do way better than this. So this should
be a very low lower bound for us.
This is how to think about these things.
Okay, we need this we need this uh term.
So
standard test eval is training on a
finite number of training levels and
evaluating performance on unseen test
levels.
Training levels are sampled from some
distribution that we call direct level
sampling.
Case of a finite train training set
you just have uniform sampling yada
yada.
Inject to state by default.
Convert things that seem obvious now
only obvious because you watch the
stream.
I think if you ask like, oh, is it
obvious that we should be doing this? I
would wager that like at least eight and
10, if not nine and 10, if you don't
lead the question, 80 to 90% of
researchers, maybe more, will just be
like, "What? No."
In fact, if you'd asked me a couple
years ago, I would have just been like,
"What no as well.
Yeah, but the thing is you already have
puffer with dogfight, right? So like the
idea was that in general we're not going
to be able to have state setable
environments because of how what crap
engineering was behind all the RLMs
before, right? So the idea that state
sets could be broadly implemented and
done fairly easily, that is new and that
is something that's been enabled by
puffer. This did not make sense before
when people were doing Atari crap. You
see what I mean?
So like the thing is the state set idea
here is not particularly brilliant at
all. It emer
given all the engineering that's already
been done on puffer.
Yes. And alpha zero was considered very
limited because of the way it uses
states. Jess,
T is going to be the length of a roll
out.
Our method is illustrated in figure one
and fully specified in algorithm 2.
Dynamic nonparametric sampling
distribution P replay of levels given
scene levels over
previously visited training levels.
I'm calling this A. I don't actually I
don't [ __ ] know what letter this is.
A scene. Um,
prioritize visit levels
e replay algene is the replay
distribution
through training our method update.
Actually, let's not be an idiot here.
What what the hell is this letter?
L.
Ah, yes. Uppercase L. Of course.
Wait, actually, what is it? What is it
pronounced as?
Oh, that's uppercase lambda.
Well, [ __ ] me, I guess.
We've preferred Pre replay as.
Well, that's even worse because it's L
given capital L scene
as replay distribution. Uh,
this is just P replay, right? The replay
distribution. So, throughout training,
our method updates replay distribution
according to a heristic score assigning
weight to visited levels with a higher
future learning potential.
This is basically what we do but with
trajectory segments.
Using dynamic arrays S and C of equal
length of equal length to a scene or LC
scene,
PLR tracks level scores
for each visited training level
based on the latest episode trajectory
as well as episode count.
A method updates pre-re replay after
each terminated episode by computing a
mixture of two distributions based on
level scores and how long ago each was
sampled. Okay, so this is like only
really useful for fixed number of levels
already, right? So this is a very big
assumption.
See, I'm actually happy that I didn't
read this up front because this would
have biased my design of the algorithm.
Replay a level sampled from the replay
distribution or to experience a new
unseen level.
Okay. So, they have this like seen
unseen thing that we don't really
assume.
the problem setup of this. So, the
problem setup of this is very limited
and it's limited because they're
assuming training levels.
It's very funny in some sense because
they actually end up making a much more
restrictive assumption than our method
in practice
thinking that they're making a less
restrictive assumption.
We employ a function of TD error.
The expectation of TD over next states.
Okay, so they're just summing onestep TD
errors or kstep TD errors.
the average magnitude of J. Yeah. So
this is what we do.
G magnitude is equal to the L1 value
loss.
cool. I like this. Very nice. This is
what we're already doing, though.
Hello, Tim. Hey, Tim. I got something to
show you.
Boy, do I have something to show you.
Welcome to Boxabon
takes two and a half hours,
but there you go.
Yeah. Percent.
So the score is a percent.
This is like score or Perf, right? It's
the same thing.
Perf is point 54 is 547 as well. Yes,
that's Perf with diff 2.
cool, right? So, I'm running a big sweep
on the baseline now to make sure that it
turn like it doesn't just turn out that
you can get this with the baseline
somehow. But yeah, we're solving 54%.
with puffer five
and also I mean if you look at this
curve this is basically linear in
compute right
so this strongly strongly suggests that
we can do way better than this just by
scaling it
didn't need incremental. We'll keep it
for now, man. But um
I don't know. I like I just went to the
difficulty too based on my results and
experience with the maze ends.
Yeah, I know. Scoring in ink is
different.
I will say it's interesting here. I do
have 13% now so far with um
with the baseline.
So, something is weird here because I
now I have I have 13% with the baseline
so far.
is actually quite good for that level of
time.
So, we're going to have to wait and see
pretty much if the baseline is just if
it turns out that this just solves.
It would be pretty weird, but we have to
run it.
stream went down right when I pushed.
That's just internet.
There's not really anything I can do
about it for now. I ordered Starlink.
It'll be here in a week.
I'm sick of dealing with the Comcast
cash [ __ ]
Isn't Palo Alto modern? No,
they they don't even have the [ __ ]
cables buried here, man.
You have changed the reward. Yeah, Tim.
But like I don't know. The hope here is
that this Perf is coming from state sets
and not just coming from the reward
changes. We will see.
If it turns out that the baseline is
just as good, um, then we have a big
problem
with five. We'll see.
Uh, just rename the folder convert.
You literally just rename the folder for
now.
It'll grab everything and it'll just use
the name of the folder for everything
this. I could try
I could try this rank prioritization
thing.
Ah, see this? I think this is wrong.
What they do right here.
So in PLR they update the score.
They do a hard update on the score. You
see this? So they sample a level, they
do roll like based on advantage. They
they compute new advantage after train
and they update the score. I think this
is a mistake
because for stuff with sparse rewards,
um, it's going to take you several
samples to see the reward again, which
is why I think my decay factor is
better.
See, I think that because they have this
thing designed for a fixed set of
levels.
I think that they like I think they deal
with this crap because they have it
designed for a fixed set of levels and
they keep it small.
Oh, wait. Rolling finite buffer of the
top level so far.
Okay, this is cool. Look,
it's only on mini grid.
Okay, they actually do have stailness in
here.
Figure three.
Well, we need to spend
Figure three. Well, we need to spend some time on this.
You know what? Let me let me just show
you all something kind of ridiculous,
right? Because this is probably one of
the better or probably the best
curriculum learning paper overall.
You see this?
They basically solve
procgen.
Um just with hyperparameter tuning.
PO baseline 1x width. I do wonder if
they actually did eval correctly.
probably not. Or maybe they just used
the full level set. That would make more
sense, right? If they just used the full
level set. But they basically solved it
with this. And then you get this pretty
small PF difference from this whole PLR.
It kind of just shows you how important
just doing basic hyper stuff is.
I know originally this was designed as a
benchmark where you're not supposed to
tune yada yada yada yada [ __ ] It
doesn't matter. The problem was framed
wrong originally.
Wait, isn't L1 supposed to be equal to
GE?
29 is only a billion, right? Yeah.
So, actually, we're already doing more
than a billion, Tim.
Oh, wait. This is the best of a
400 sweep run.
Yeah. Okay. So, you're just not getting
any signal there because you're only
seeing 50 mil steps.
See, the thing is they're getting
92% with a CNN.
Presumably, they just have big like big
nets, right?
This is also on the um the train set as
well.
So the gap basically goes away when you
have the full um full train set anyways,
right?
Yeah. So, we're just assuming we have
enough levels.
Yeah, presumably they're using much more
compute, Tim.
I mean, like I don't know how much ours
will scale, but it's quite possible that
we end up getting somewhere up there.
Um,
cuz we have linear scaling with time and
we're literally using less than three
GPU hours right now.
We're not doing step constrained
[ __ ] either.
Let's figure this out.
So
useful interpretation
observation that J
Then why are these giving different
results?
Math needs double checking there.
Okay, but they do have this metric at
the least.
And then they have what's this P and
beta.
It's kind of screwy in a way, right?
Because you're introducing extra
hyperparameters on a benchmark that's
purely tuned.
It's This is like a poorly tuned.
Little sketched out on some of this. I
got to chat with Ryan.
though. This right here,
this is very consistent with the type of
stuff that I've been seeing,
right? this fast takeoff.
Let's get some ablations.
Oh, you don't have ablations? Are you
kidding me?
Is there an appendix for this thing,
Oh, is it one of those stupid ones where
it's like a separate?
Does this have the appendix?
No.
Where's the damn appendex?
There's no appendex,
right?
Wait, this looks longer. Ah, this has
the appendex.
Okay, look.
This is what we wanted.
Interesting. They actually have very
very low
prioritization here.
And then they have this steness
parameter.
Interesting.
Oh, I guess maybe there actually maybe
there is something to that.
We'll have to think about that. That is
an interesting thing though.
Only helps on some of the ends.
You see this?
Oh, wait. No. Are they doing Hang on.
No, cuz they're comparing to they they
have the soda here bolded. Okay. It
actually does help way more
consistently. You see,
Yeah, this is a much better gap here.
Okay.
I'm happier with this.
Do they have another graph with
they have a lot of experiments? This
must have been expensive.
Test performance of PLR plus rank
prioritization.
Okay, so no prioritization is crap.
And it looks like any amount of
prioritization works, but somewhere in
the middle is good.
Too much is not great. Gotcha.
Anything else on I want to just make
sure I didn't miss a graph that answers
the exact question I had.
Uh, you don't have a graph, do you? Damn
it.
Okay, so the one thing I really don't
understand from this
goal for today,
um, under I just gen generically make
progress on puffer 5. Uh, this paper
gives us a lot of ideas for things we
Okay, so yeah, we should be live here.
Okay, so this is the thing I don't
understand, guys.
You see they have generalized advantage
estimation here in blue and then they
have it here and then they have L1 value
loss which is very close here and very
far away here.
Yeah, I know it's going to be cutting
out for a couple seconds every so often
all day. Um I can't do anything about
it. Go yell at Comcast.
I've ordered Starlink. It'll be here in
like within a week and then I just won't
have to deal with this crap.
But here's the thing that I really don't
understand. So J and L1 value loss.
Should be the same here.
Edge four.
contract in exchange for a stable
connection. Hell no.
Oh, is that what it is?
Did they Did it actually find it that
quickly?
Okay, that's actually pretty impressive.
They got it that quickly.
Yeah, this is the exact chunk of code
though.
Oh, look. They're literally doing it the
same way. It's just abs.
Okay, so L1 is this is what I'm already
doing.
Yeah, Tim, I have Starlink on the way.
85 bucks here
for 200 megabits,
which I'm not going to like the speeds
that much to be honest with you. That'll
be annoying for a few things with
Docker, but um at the very least it'll
be stable hopefully.
Yeah, California is very weird in that
like you have a bunch of very normal
looking houses that would be 400k
elsewhere in the country that are just
suddenly worth 3 to 4 million each and
like the infrastructure is still the
same as you would expect in an area
where the houses are 400k. So, it's just
very [ __ ] weird.
But hey, people pay in the tens of
millions for fancy apartments in New
York. So, let's be thankful that those
people exist because that means there's
arbitrage on things that we actually
like.
30 acres. Yeah. Yeah. That's the way to
go. convert.
I don't know, Jess. I would personally
be happy if um if the cities like I
think that there are a bunch of people
that just want to be in super dense
cities and would be very happy if the
cities were much denser than they are
now. And then there are a bunch of
people who want to be nowhere the hell
near any of that crap. And we'd be much
happier if suburbs and rural areas were
much sparer. So that would be the best
the best outcome in my mind.
UK mind cannot comprehend.
I think that you can kind of just do
that in the US man.
Like there are a number of areas where
you can do that and it's not even that
ridiculously expensive to do so.
Um you know you'll be in the middle of
nowhere but you'll still be within
like say 40 minutes of a hospital and 30
minutes of reasonable groceries and
amenities.
All right. Well this is good. So, we
figured out this chunk of um this myth
here.
Thank you, Codeex.
Um it's kind of funny because look, it
the wording is a little screwy here
because it looks like this is what
they're calling J, but they are using
actual J. So, we're already using the
best metric.
So, the two things that we can play with
are the rank transform
and staleness, which is good.
Now, we're not going to like shift this
onto politics, though. This is a tech
stream. Jess,
we will go to tech.
Uh 14. Okay, so we're at 14% solve rate
on baseline and 1,600 uptime.
We still have to let this run a whole
bunch. Um
I will be pretty damn surprised if this
just works.
Well, I guess if this just let's see.
Let's actually think what this means.
Um, if it just turns out that the
baseline works and our thing doesn't
help, I think it just means we have a
very shitty version of
uh we have a very shitty version of PLR
applied to segments. In some sense, it
works for the sparse mazes because
that's the perfectly suited task. And
then we just have to kind of ablate
things until we can get there.
No, this is not a white paper stream
today. It's just that this one paper PLR
is very relevant because this
essentially does what I want to do or my
paper, but they do it over whole levels
whereas we do stuff over trajectory
segments. So, we should have a much much
more powerful approach than PLR. Um, and
they have a couple things in here that I
can draw from. in particular. I think
that the last hour was worth it because
of I learned about this thing. Where is
it? Where's the rank transform?
Yeah, rank right here. Prioritize by
rank.
So, this change in metric alone in my
mind is worthwhile. This should be
substantially more robust. We can try
this next, but I'm hoping that we at
least get something reasonable out of
our initial sweep first.
If it turns out the baselines work,
Puffer is great still. And it turns out
reward matter. Yeah, but Tim, like so in
my mind, if I were just trying some
random thing that could or could not
work. Like last summer with the off
policy, I'd say okay, maybe the idea is
bad. In this case, I am positive that
the idea is good. Like I'm positive that
um state sets will make a difference if
implemented well. And if they don't work
well here, it means that we've just have
a stupid version of using them,
which is a bit annoying because the
sweeps take a while to get right.
baseline won't get that good. State sets
has better results in it yet.
Um Tim, I don't think that you'll get
anything better out of the state set
result. Like you won't shift the curve
up, but I think that if you run it for
longer, yes, you will be able to get it
to do um you will be able to get it to
continue to do better. But like that
kind of doesn't matter for us for now.
What matters is the shape of the PTO
curve. That's the thing we're evaluating
obviously for release. I'm going to
scale it and we're going to try to match
um we're going to try to shift the curve
out as far as we can obviously.
Okay. So, that's like that's at least a
little bit of progress for now.
16. Yeah, that's fine. So, that's a
little bit of progress for now. I'm
happy with that.
curve space and state. Yes, exactly Tim,
which is what we will do.
How many results do you have on boxman
with and without state sets? Would it be
worth? So, uh, we don't have enough
results with out state sets yet. We
don't have enough on the baseline.
So, I basically I ran the state set
version first because if that doesn't
work, there's no point in running the
baseline.
Oh, it just found a 19. This just found
09 on the baseline in 3600.
Yeah, we only have 194 results so far in
Voxabon. And we have uh I believe we
have 600
Oh, it's actually not that many more.
It's 279.
I guess we could go grab it real quick.
No harm.
What do you consider more complex?
So uh there are two versions of that
liberty. There are complex environments
from a benchmarking perspective that are
like I as a researcher based on my
understanding of RL am very confident
that these are high confident like that
these are good environments where doing
better on them is very indicative of
results elsewhere and the ends
themselves are hard. Then there is the
these ends look pretty and impressive to
other people. Those are two very
different things.
Um, we will do some of both. Obviously,
we focus on the actually informative M's
or core research and the showcase M are
needed for us to still have a business
and people to hire us because not
everybody's an RL expert. So, sometimes
you have to show people things they can
understand.
Um, in my mind, Sokaban is very very
much like a core research environment.
Um, it's a very very hard env. It's
dramatically harder than pretty much
anything that I've gotten from a client.
And uh perfure will transfer Oh,
Oh, and then I have to move breakout,
don't I?
So, we're basically we have to see now,
right?
Yeah. So if this curve goes out this
way,
that would be consistent with
expectation.
We pretty much we have to wait and see
what happens when we get more of these
runs.
If it ends up like this, I will say that
would be consistent with 2048.
Based on the gap, we'll know how um
we'll know where we stand.
It's harder in the sense that the
learning problem itself is harder than
client work. Tim, there are a lot of
externalities with our professional
work, right? That like the problems tend
to be a lot messier, but then the actual
problem once you get it set up correctly
is uh much easier to solve.
peace. What are we puffing?
Uh, we've got SOA bond baselines running
now.
We're essentially testing first version
of the puffer 5 algorithm.
And what time is it? 12:30.
I think there's really not much for me
to do other than wait on uh wait on the
experiments. I think I probably should
just start merging in some environments
and playing with things.
Well, I don't know about merging.
I guess we can kind of just play around
with crafter and craft axe a little bit
as well as overcooked.
I'd very much like to have those on the
website.
I'll be right back. Some of the kernel
stuff
kernel stuff is pretty heavy, Jess. And
merging that has the potential to mess
with other things I'm doing. I don't
want to have any possible reasons that
our experiment results get screwy. And I
don't want to merge like I don't want to
touch that until I have the five
algorithms stable.
I think I'd rather do some end stuff
um while we wait on the other
experiments.
Thank you very much, Tim. Either way,
this will be a very very useful research
environment. So, this is a great
contribution.
Coding game en
coding game. If it's textbased, it's not
a good fit for puffer. I'll be right
back.
Oh, wait. Coding game.
Maybe I'm thinking of the wrong thing.
I'll be right back.
AI bot programming challenges.
Um, if you can set it up such that the
Do you need to script the bot or can it
directly be controlled by low-level
actions?
If it's the latter, then sure.
Did you already play with OSRS Inferno?
So,
Inferno is um Valla's project and it
will be a core test for Puffer 5, but it
is a big enough project with enough
moving parts that I would prefer to test
on mazes and soaban first
and then um think of it like this,
right? We're going to essentially use
mazes and soapon as the dev set of ends
and then we'll test it by running a
sweep but not having to change the
algorithm at all on Inferno.
All right, let's get on to
we'll do stuff on a combination of the
local box and um puffer max, I think.
And then we'll essentially overcooked
and uh crafter, I believe, will be the
ends.
Do that. Oh yeah, also let's just get
make sure we're still sshed in here. Let
me check the vast credit so we don't
drop the box.
163. Okay, we're still good for a few
hours.
Many hours actually.
You know all that grass in those 30
acres? Go touch it.
Yes, Jess. That's why I stuck um Spencer
on Robo Code.
Okay, cool. We're good now. We can just
start on this. Um,
anything here?
No, we don't need this anymore. Where?
I guess we should probably start with
this one.
It's already set up for this.
I'm not going to manually edit the AI
gen code.
this is what we're going to do
here.
We're just going to write like um like a
simple spec of what changed in four to
five and then it'll just be easier to do
this on all the ends.
Internet flipping literally every other
minute is awful.
I don't think I'd be able to go to South
Korea for the conference.
Deadline was 18th.
Wait, what?
How can they have
dude email them because h if how can you
have found out about the paper now
and the deadline for applying to the
conference be before that because the
travel grants are supposed to prioritize
authors, right? That makes no sense.
Just email that. figure out how to email
and write them a polite a short but
polite email
um on that say you know like hey I'm an
author I won't be able to attend the
conference if you know I don't have a
grant um obviously I wasn't going to
know I wouldn't have known to apply to
this thing if I didn't know the paper I
was going to get in yada yada
if you politely explain your situation.
Quite possibly.
Some M's are not updated to 40.
All the core M's are updated to 40 Bram.
There like some unfinished ones and some
very minor test ms that weren't updated,
but like pretty much all the core stuff
is There.
So, um, to give you an idea as to what
I'm doing and why I'm letting just
codeex do this, uh, the updates to
Puffer 5 are very easy.
They're essentially there's no room for
screwing with them in some sense. Like
there's kind of only one way to do it.
Um there's minimal stuff you can screw
up in the process. So
this is fine.
Okay, this is still the best result so
far.
203.
So, it's got like another 60 something
experiments to run for parody.
Wasn't Puffer 5 planned for Christmas
this year?
Uh, puffer five will be earlier in
puffer five will be end of summer
unless like all hell breaks loose on the
algorithm side.
But basically we'll know that by today
like if um if there's a substantial gap
in performance like if state sets does
substantially better on Soaban we are
essentially guaranteed that all core
work uh for this update is done this
week and you know just whatever else we
figure like putting in will be smaller
like nicer like nice small things
and like we'll be well well done by the
end of the summer.
This is so funny. I have this side tab
here and uh hang on. There's
there's somebody in the lab that started
like that was in my lab um
yeah there was somebody in my lab at MIT
who started playing Runescape after me
and just really really plays the game a
lot.
What in the [ __ ]
Okay, this is actually just like a
disgusting amount of gameplay. What the
[ __ ]
Let me not leak the username, but okay.
Started playing after me.
Is maxed
has done postmax
pet hunts
on multiple scales. It looks like
Yeah, this is pet hunt KC. Jesus. 580.
Okay, that's just obscene.
Jesus.
Not sure if has graduated yet.
Presumably so. But Jesus Christ.
I mean, that's got to be like six hours
average a day.
Uh, you have a a very overinflated
view of um
MIT students.
Yeah, an is like literally right. No,
I'm not an iron. This is a main. Mine is
a main. That's not my account on the
high scores. This is mine.
I have a I have probably way too many
hours in this game as is, but at least a
good chunk of them are like side monitor
content.
Um
I I don't know Anish is I found a lot of
the people I met at MIT to be very
uninspiring.
Are you doing puffer to it?
I mean we are actually doing puffer on
Runescape environments. like that's
going to be one of the main tests for
Puffer 5. We've got two separate people
that have now ported collectively
close to 100,000 lines of code um of
like private server code from Runescape
over into C.
Obviously, with that amount of code and
that few people, it's very LLM crappy,
but it's one of the things that is very
verifiable and it's done by people who
actually do understand what they're
doing. So, it's not just like vibe coded
complete crap.
And it's going to be very efficient as
well.
how to use side play.
So, this is literally I click this like
once um every minute or two and
it so it doesn't distract you.
Obviously, more complicated stuff than
that would be distracting
while I'm working,
but the game is kind of set up so that
there's a lot of stuff like that in it.
You learn C, dude. It's not short of
learning C. You just learned C. I know.
Camera froze. I fixed it. I unplugged it
because it [ __ ] up.
Um, there's some driver shenanigans.
I put it back. It should be fine now,
right?
At least it was froz before I had it
unplugged. It was frozen on my screen.
Maybe it wasn't frozen for you guys,
but whatever. Now it's fixed for both.
Okay, this is fine. This is just moving
things.
So,
So you see even for something like this
I still have to just not brain off hit
tab tab tab right
because it'll do stupid [ __ ] like look
at this macro crap
head.
Oh yeah, pepper.
There you go. That's what you need.
Oops.
I'm going to be honest. I've never even
read that book.
I got it recently, but I've read pretty
much no programming textbooks ever. Like
obviously I've I've like done a bunch of
formal learning on
on everything, but I've never been the
type to um to get my information from
like really long textbooks
towards Zuck.
Uh, no. We actually, so it's between the
two contributors, there's going to be
fight caves, Zuck, Zulra, and PvP.
And then it's also it's set up so that
you can add new ends as well.
I've barely started it, Jess.
It realized I'm going to [ __ ] at it.
So, it's starting to do smaller things
so I can like review them.
Yep,
this is correct.
I'll do awaken vard.
I'm going to be honest with you, our
model will smash awaken vard in like
probably 30 seconds.
As long as you get the observations
right, I'll be surprised if it even
takes 30 seconds for it to learn perfect
awakened fart.
It's just not that hard for um a model.
And I still can't do that boss on the
main game. It was a total [ __ ] even on
leagues.
No, Braum. There's probably quite a bit
we can do to um improve the speed. Like
we've had a couple people look at
things, but as far as kernel development
goes, I'm quite amateur at that. I have
a lot to learn. Um I'd also like to make
sure that we keep stuff simpler in the
process of making it fast.
There's probably still quite a bit of
room, though. I think that the biggest
room that we'd have at the moment would
be um we'd have to come up with some
improvements to the map moles.
There's probably just like some settings
or whatever that we I haven't played
with yet cuz we don't have kernel
search. We don't even we're not even
checking like launch args or anything.
22.
Okay, this is starting to find better
stuff.
We will see whether um
whether we have big advantage over
baseline.
I do hope we do.
Okay, this actually we're going to have
to review.
I try an ish.
Oh, wait. I missed him. How feasible do
you think it would be to string those
RSMs together? Uh yeah, that's kind of
the idea longer term. Jess
gauntlet from beginning to end. Uh that
would be a good one. And I do think it
would be able to do that. Like we're
doing inferno, right?
Inferno is much longer than gauntlet
speed increases mainly GPU based ocean
speed. There are some changes for end
speed that would help.
We have a couple things landing soon
that will help like a bunch of ends.
One of the big ones right now is
decreasing bandwidth. So, uh, we're
going to probably land soon Bflat
observation encoding. That will help.
There's probably some stuff you could do
with our threading model as well, though
it's a little complicated.
Okay, you see that here? So, it looks
like it's changing a lot of code, but if
you look at what it's actually doing,
it's basically just swapping in N, which
used to be the full strruct with S.
I'm just making sure it's not doing
anything crazy.
This is a little bothersome though.
I mean, that's right on par with that's
right on par with our existing stuff,
man.
PvP has learned to game all scripted
policies by maging from 10 tiles away
with mage prey on.
The funny thing is that's the type of
stuff that you actually do in LMS when
they uh you know when they deploy new
bot scripts. I've literally done that
before, man. Like far cast with mage
with crossbow on. I've literally done
that [ __ ]
That's actually pretty good.
I'm pretty sure they're actually there.
I distinctly remember this now actually,
right? because it wouldn't know how to
put its crossbow on m on long range. So,
it would just stand there if you would
just um you keep protect mage on and
then you mage from 10 tiles away. Yeah,
it literally would do that
I mean, this is the type of cool stuff
though that you know when you actually
play the game. Like that was actually a
strat against the bots.
There's also the one tick like just you
one tick everything. So you basically
ignore you ignore everything and you
just one tick your whip.
That was also one for a while because it
it never tries to predict. It just tries
to it always just matches one tick
delay.
We live.
We're back alive.
Literally, at least I get a disconnect
at least every hour, but I'm getting
micro bumps like constantly. Constantly
annoying as hell.
All right, let's just review this.
Wait, I did this one. What's the next
one?
Uh, this is fine.
Yeah, look, it's just N replace with S
and replace with S and replace with S.
That one's a little screwy.
We'll get a diff afterwards and we'll
mend the diff.
I mean, that's a good thing, right?
The goal is to not is not to bot the
game, right? This is for research. Why
would I want to ruin my favorite him.
depending on how good it gets follow. It
would be really cool to see if um
you know we could get one of the
uh like the good NH stakers
to uh to see if they can beat it.
I definitely want the bots out of the
damn game.
Some of them really, really break stuff.
Like the Doom bots especially. Those
need to just be gone. gone.
It's sim to sim vol.
I mean, or we could make the client
decent enough that like they could just
play
Yeah.
Yeah, I've thought about it. It's not
really a good RL fit problem. Jess
Oh, it gets a whole bunch of crap at the
moment.
If this if the rank transform thing
worked, that'd be very interesting.
Why did it try to build this
dummy?
I started watching
the
math is going over my head. What's your
math background?
So
like the only real math in 231N is
derivative. You need to know what a
derivative is. Um,
yes, it's multivariable, but like it
really doesn't get much harder as a
result.
I guess there are cross terms for some
things.
Multivariate derivative calculus is
useful. You do need to understand the
fundamentals of that. You're not going
to be working out a lot of derivatives
by hand, though it actually does come
up.
Well, high school math can mean a lot of
different things because I' i'd seen
that through high school, right?
Multivariate derivative calculus is
something you need. Um, mind you, that
is
in some sense that's the most accessible
piece of math because it's fully
mechanical. There's no art to it.
and in particular the way that it is
applied
um in ML is very very simple
you will have to actually do the
exercises in the course by the way you
can't just write the you can't just
watch the lectures like you got to go
implement some layers and off.
Yeah, and that's the annoying thing with
having to do local state obs,
but rendering is just so bloody
expensive. And even if you did render,
the obs would be so large.
It's pretty much always worth it to just
extract state.
Okay, it's not adding um macros. That's
already there.
Having local state almost feels like
cheating.
are all your boxes down? Down. You have
like 10. No, they shouldn't be.
What's wrong with the boxes?
One, two, three, four, five. We've got
five of the uh the single GP ones up.
I've got two extras of those.
That's seven. Um, and then one of the
tiny boxes is up.
The reason I'm doing [ __ ] on vast is
because my m one of my multiGPU box is
down. Unless I've gotten a reply to
this.
Either way, I'm going to have to finish
this run.
Okay. Actually, I did get a message
today. So, we'll see if this comes back.
Thank you for reminding me. That was
very useful.
Thank you very very much for reminding
me. Yeah, puffer boxes just have one GPU
each. Tiny box has um those have six
each.
So, thank you very much for that.
Cool. I actually can do other things
today. Very nice.
It's also just dramatically more
convenient to have my own hardware than
to have to use shitty vast
Yeah, Valo, I wouldn't worry about
visual stuff to be honest with you.
Like
so much of RL has been done on pixel M.
It works. It's just slow. That's all.
There's really nothing to it.
In some sense, state estimation is the
easiest damn thing to train.
Architecturally, many things get easier
with pixels. They just get slow.
Yeah, I can tell that this was written
with um with Claude or Codeex.
the same as just seeing the piece
positions.
I mean
not seeing the board.
Yeah, I don't think it's a dramatically
harder problem. Volo, I think that you
learn like those correlations you learn
very easily.
You just burn compute. Like I don't
think you change anything at all about
the method. I guess if you feel like it,
you can train um
like you can train a basic
encoder for it,
but nothing really changes with pixels
other than you burn GPUs.
I might get rid of the 3090.
Wait, mine has
Wait, Tim, why don't you
wait, why don't you just plug your
monitors in if it's your local desktop,
why don't you plug your monitors into
the 3090 and then use your 5090 for
sweep so that you don't lag your screen
when you run experiments.
All right. All right. So, we're just
deleting all of the memory allocations
cuz it's all going to be static.
Okay, this only has like 50 more
experiments.
It's only got like 50 more experiments.
So, we'll see
if this is uh going to be as good or
not.
We're going to finish this one.
Probably do overcooked.
Maybe sweep this.
I mean, realistically, right,
we've got two M's here
that we can use.
We have
I still don't think these are going to
be Well, who knows? Maybe craft axe will
be a good benchmark. En I think crafter
is too easy.
It'll look cool, but it'll just be a
showcase end. I think craft axe, if it's
fast though, will be good.
Oh yeah, Robbocode will be a nice hen,
though I don't think that'll be a
showcase. That's kind of in the middle.
I guess if it learns really cool looking
selfplay policies, maybe
uh convert, I have enough stuff to do
without beta testing the ends. When you
have it ready though, I'll be happy to
look at it.
Oh, no.
Oh, it is heavier. 54% M time.
Yeah, this is just stupid small network.
Okay, cool.
Um, I'm going to use the restroom real
quick and
we'll see what uh what ends next. Be
right back.
How much do you bench? Er is 275.
That was
about a month ago.
I'm on a bit of a cut now, though.
That was probably I weighed
185.
I'm mostly running at the moment for the
summer.
Hang on. I I just want to get my
thoughts clear here for the 50 update.
Um,
too many wires are getting crossed in my
head. So, we do need to update all the
M's. Um, other than me having to make
sure stuff doesn't get screwed up.
That's mostly just codecs. So updating
M's very easy, right?
There are a few small tweaks we have to
make to our end format
that we probably want to do before I
port too many of the ends. That's no big
deal.
We have a few demo ms where we basically
just have to run a sweep and um test it.
It doesn't particularly matter if we do
that sooner or later.
I think it's probably even better to do
that later. So, we have sweeps on the
release version.
There are a few other small things we
can sweep to be fair.
I could sweep breakout without um
without reward clipping.
I mean there are two things that we want
to test on the algo side, right?
like it's not that complicated.
I can actually what I can do is when I I
can finish this and then I can get that
one set up.
What's Robocode? So, Robocode is this
old um programming competition
environment that was used in a lot of
Java courses that um for like new
programmers, but then a lot of slightly
more experienced people would build uh
really good bots for it. It's this um
one v one typically or like one v
multiple whatever ank battle game and
the dynamics are pretty nice and I
figured it would make a good self-play
environment. I started implementing it a
long time ago. Um, Tossin
made some contributions to it and I had
Spencer work on finishing it. Any weight
loss drugs on the cut?
No, just like
run and not eat a lot. I mean, look,
cutting is easy for me. I have a very
low appetite to begin with.
So,
I mean, in order to gain weight in the
first place, I basically have to stuff
myself.
Like, in my mind, that that's the
easiest part of any of it, right? The
hard part is doing the training on a
cut.
This one is not going to be as bad as
last summer. Last summer there were some
extenduating circumstances where like
basically I'd gained enough weight that
it would have it would have I got to a
body fat percentage that it would have
been virtually impossible for me to get
to naturally.
Um,
and actually in that case there
just last summer was uh last summer was
brutal. This one's not as bad. This is
like a 10 lb cut
most likely.
And the extra 10 pounds this time was
pretty much just from me not having the
energy to train enough and not wanting
to lose my muscle. So just like
basically force-feeding myself a little
bit too much to not lose muscle um
during the puffer 4 development.
And this was the plan anyways was to do
that and then cut in the summer.
and then we'll set up the experiment on
the other machine.
A little sketchy to try them on
different machines though, isn't it?
I think it'll be okay.
I think it'll be all right.
You just not like food. That's I just
don't have the appetite to eat 3 to
4,000 calories worth of food.
Like
it's moderately difficult, I guess, for
me to do a 1500 calorie cut. But if I
did a 700 calorie cut a day, like I
wouldn't even notice that. That would
just be like, "Oh yeah, I'm I'm not
stuffing myself. I'm eating the actual
amount of food that I want." And that
would like that would include just
eating random pastries and [ __ ] as well.
Robot Rage.
Let me look this up.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, it's like a 3D tank bottle.
Well, it's a little irritating to me
that um now we're going to have the
experiments on different machines.
Let it do this. And then what we'll do
is we'll set up we'll set up a new set
of sweeps on this.
Okay, we're still at 22%
with the original algorithm,
if it essentially turns out that um
the state set method as it is now
essentially just helps you with long
runs.
Well, this will be really good data
though either way, won't it?
This will be really good data.
Oh, yeah. It can do whatever it wants.
This is just tests.
These are throwaways.
I look at this as just like, you know,
increased confidence that nothing stupid
got [ __ ] up with simple routine
refactor.
Not like for sure nothing got [ __ ] up,
but we should be okay. And I also
checked all the code changes. Um,
Didn't I have something running here?
Actually,
I did. Okay, let's let me deal with
that.
I don't know why this is running
experiments way the [ __ ] out here.
So the baseline is a little better here,
isn't it?
And also the sweep is just very screwy
on this.
But I suppose for now we just keep the
um
we keep the optimizer changes
before we can validate them more
extensively.
Oh yeah, we don't need to. We're fine
here. So, we just go like this.
Yeah, Casper. So, that's going to be um
that will be added to Puffer 5. It's a
very small, easy change to make. Um it
will support different types of Ms, but
like most of the game type Ms we use for
testing don't need it.
that will be more useful for
the types of things that we plan on
doing uh with full stable RL like once
all of our stuff is super good, super
stable. I mean it is compared to
everything else but I mean the bar in my
mind is RL is a mature stable field that
just works and then that is when the
environments that will need GPU
acceleration become relevant. And I'm
not referring to simple robotics
problems. That [ __ ] we could do now very
easily.
and launch one more experiment off of
this.
Please tell me that this is still
reasonable.
So far so good. What would require GPU
anyways?
So my top interest long term
um my top top interest longer term is
biological sim.
I think also material science simulation
will be cool as well.
I don't know anything about these areas
other than people use a bunch of sims
and they use them in a very primitive
way
and probably having sims that can
optimize towards an objective will be
useful.
But I don't like the reason I don't
really want to go into it too much yet
is because
or is that um
in my mind you want to be approaching
hard learning problems where
interpretability is limited from a point
of RL is stable and just works.
And we're going to be very very close to
RL is stable and just works very soon
within this coming year.
so they're essentially from reading the
PLR paper um there are two things that
jumped out to me that we could
potentially change in the algorithm. One
is applying a rank transform to the
absolute advantage estimate
that just like replaces each value with
the index of that value in a sorted
array.
And uh the other one is
a staleness factor
upweight stale
advance stale values though I don't
actually that one doesn't make as much
sense to me.
Let's see what we got here.
We're going to have to see what the
hell's going on with this thing. This
will be easy though, right? We'll just
test the breakout speed after and see if
it's stupid and slow.
I mean,
it's going to get less than 50
additional experiments to run.
I am a little bit concerned though that
if you just sweep it longer, maybe it
finds better stuff.
That's kind of the point of the whole
thing, Casper.
There not really many places where this
level of um science just happens in the
open.
And it's actually something that you can
just start contributing to right now if
you feel like it. You know, many of the
um it's all open source. Many of the
contributors came in with zero AI
experience.
It's a great place to learn ML RL
low-level programming.
The minimal useful contribution like the
bar is not that that high in the sense
that um a lot of relatively simple to
implement environments end up being
useful.
I don't think that this is actually
using sampling, is it?
can't follow what you do.
Well, I mean, you're not watching the
easy parts now. Like,
I'm not always working on easy stuff.
To be fair, what I'm doing now feels
pretty easy for me, but like this is
based on three different papers that I
have in my head, right? and a whole
bunch of experimental results that I'm
constantly reweing the evidence of
buttons.
Yeah, we're alive.
Stupid internet, man.
I thought it was doing [ __ ] bubble
sort.
I saw that and I was like, is it bubble
sort? Yep, it's using bubble sort.
How we doing on the baseline?
Oh, it just got a new one. 28%
2,800 uptime.
I don't know, man. We're going to see.
The baseline is doing surprisingly well.
I mean, we expect there to still be a
big gap, but who knows? I have more
things to test.
What does that say? If the baseline does
good,
um,
I guess good point. It says puffer is
freaking cracked.
No, there really can't be any major
impulse fuckups as far as I uh I'm
aware. There.
Oh, by the way, this thing is um
clearly, you know, PhD level
intelligence and everything. implements
[ __ ] bubble sort.
Um,
I actually think that in terms of like
at least addressing the major challenges
that are preventing RL from being
broadly mostly out of the box, I think
we're within a year.
Jesus [ __ ] stop this [ __ ] man.
in my mind crit like I think that for
basically any medium complexity problem
that would have previously taken
uh a year's worth of work by a
by a domain expert, we kind of just
solve it out of the box given a
reasonably set up
I mean, this is just incredibly stupid,
right?
It basically goes and sees an obvious
obvious C99 codebase and tries to use
[ __ ] C++
algorithm
like piss off.
Going to restore. Hang on, let me see.
Restore heat behavior
Yep.
That's it.
My I'm not [ __ ] thinking correctly. I
don't care. It's whatever.
It just occurred to me.
is very funny.
It's still using [ __ ] bubble sword,
isn't it?
Yes, there is a built-in sea sort. There
literally is.
It's literally bubble sort, right?
Am I seeing [ __ ]
I literally gave it the architecture and
it still comes up with [ __ ]
Like this is the simplest damn thing
ever, right? You have a bunch of stuff.
It needs to be sorted, but all the
appends happen at the exact same time.
So you just make the buffer longer than
you need and you sort it once. Easy. And
then you only look at the top K
elements. It's so easy, right?
Okay, this is better. And now it calls Q
sort. You see this?
That's what you're supposed to do. You
write a little comparison function like
this. It's a little annoying, right? But
you write a little comparison function
like this and um then you just call the
CQ sort.
Super easy.
Look, I mean importing algorithm is
forgivable because it is a CUDA
codebase. So it just assumes, oh, I can
write C++. It doesn't realize that it's
supposed to be CUDA C.
But implementing [ __ ] bubble sword is
batshit. That's insane.
So, Codex can be PhD level intelligence
under human supervision.
No codeex can output useful stuff when
micromanaged by a human PhD.
We don't even have a heap anymore. What
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
Okay, it's just updating comments.
Whatever.
I don't even want to like spend too much
time on this cuz this is literally
possibly all throwaway, right? Like this
is just us testing an alternative
heristic
for sampling
from the PLR paper.
Are there any ocean ms you would like
optimized more that no one else is
working on?
Optimized more.
Well, it depends how much you want to um
get into stuff. So,
the one that would be really cool that
comes to mind, um, we have this Impulse
Wars environment that uses Box 2D,
and it would be a really awesome end,
but it's just too slow, and it's also
like probably thousands of lines of code
too long because of Box 2D.
Now, evidently Box 2D is actually
supposed to be very well optimized, but
a lot of what it's doing is opaque, and
I suspect that there are a lot of
shortcuts that could be taken.
It's based on um it's Captain Space
Hooks MS. It's it's based on Retrograde
Arena
No, it didn't change heavily on the
environment side, Pepper.
Like,
wait, what do you mean if I'm not using
Puffarel.py?
If you're not using puffer.py,
then you're going to have to use our
veend implementations
because we no longer expose individual
environments at the Python level.
Um, we have a vecend exposed interface
and the ends themselves, it's pretty
much just like the rewards and terminals
become float type, actions become float
type. Um, you have to manage your own
RNG so that stuff is reproducible and
then there are a few changes to how we
do the bindings.
I want that Python exposed. You don't
because as soon as you expose the
Python, you're looping in Python and
your PF is gone anyways.
Well, why aren't you using puffer is my
question.
Like just using our M's without using
our training code, nothing is going to
be remotely close to um as fast or as
good as our training code.
Okay, this is fine.
1 to 2 mil.
Yeah, but like our algorithm is not just
PO.
You're within 90% of puffer like on hard
tasks because PO is not within 90% of
puffer on harder tasks.
Heck, even the architecture in 40 is
much better
now doing the whole performance thing.
But like what do you mean you're doing
the whole performance thing? Like what
are you trying to do?
Like what are you trying to do with
custom puffer?
config driven. Oh jeez.
Good luck.
Um, yeah, PyTorch is in CA. PieTorch
cannot get within a factor of two or
even I don't think three of our current
PF.
I mean, I literally just sent a client
an update this morning where I ported
their N to 40 and training got four and
a half times faster for the same level
of Perf.
It's not just going to be because of
dictionary overhead.
Like we can hit 20 mil end to end
training.
We can hit 40 to 60 mil in inter uh
inference.
I think maybe even more. I haven't even
bothered testing that.
Am I an idiot? Am I on the wrong [ __ ]
machine?
Uh, snake I haven't messed with in a
while.
bot will unnecessarily send like two
fleets of four.
If it's sending them one tick apart,
like why do you care?
More math for the end of to run.
What do you mean more math for the end
to run?
Oh,
I'll just make the end fast enough to
not care.
then you're fine. Just like why are you
so worried about that, man?
There's way more important stuff you can
care about.
I swear if it put bubble if it's snuck
bubble back in, I'm going to flip.
It is Q sort.
Good.
Much better.
Still some overhead,
but better enough to test it, I'd say.
Not bad.
So all we do is we leave it on this
right.
Oh actually no hang on.
We leave it on
Yeah. on this
and we leave this and we're good.
Actually that'll just sweep correctly.
For folks who didn't hear earlier, um I
did order Starlink, so the internet
situation will be resolved within the
week,
but there's not much I can do about it
now. Comcast is just a piece of [ __ ]
I'm honestly surprised there even is an
episode convert. It's too easy of a
target for them,
I would think.
All
right, I'll be right back. I'm near the
restroom and uh we'll consider what we
do for the rest of the afternoon.
So, as usual, you only think clearly the
moment you get up from the desk.
Um,
I don't think that this rank transform
is a good idea
despite what the PLR paper says
because obviously for sparse reward
environments,
most of the rewards are going to be zero
and you really care about capturing that
big spike in advantage.
I think that this rank thing makes more
sense for denser ends
or perhaps if you're not normalizing
your advantages.
The advantage norm thing is interesting
as well.
I actually think there's probably a lot
more to get just from playing around
with the advantage norm and stuff.
This talon sword.
I guess can we think about
advantage normalization for a second?
I think that the better thing to do
would be to normalize versus um
what like a running mean of discounted
reward.
Well, I've wanted some time to play with
a few things,
but maybe we'll just play with a few
things here.
So first of all, let's take state sets
off
and just play with a few algorithmic
things.
Funny that totally messes up learning,
huh?
Okay, we'll leave this for now.
What about advantage normalization?
Now, we're just playing with a few
different things right now. Just there a
few little tidbits of things I wanted to
sort of just play around with.
Okay.
Is this um
No, this is just the big kernel, isn't
it?
Where are we computing our advantage
here?
Does anybody have oblations on advantage
norm? I wonder.
Can we replace it with something?
Yeah, it's probably fused into the loss.
One of the problems with this repo.
I do wonder like it's probably not
reasonable to expect this to work
without re uh returning hypers, right?
Oops.
Uh, I don't believe that it actually
applied it, did
Okay. I mean that is interesting, isn't
it?
Could we test a um a small problem with
this?
Obviously, we're not going to be able to
just like ship this on its own.
I'm actually very surprised that trains
just as well.
So should actually fix the entropy
[ __ ] as well, right?
what entropy [ __ ] So normalizing
the advantage
um even when there's zero reward was
forcing the policy weights to shift all
around and it was essentially
determinizing the policy even with a
small entropy bonus when there was
nothing to optimize. Nice.
Okay, this messed up this which is
interesting.
Advantage is supposed to be error in the
value function, right?
I'm trying to think if you would scale
by mean like running mean or what.
Hey, look at this. This literally just
cited
This just cited my own paper.
Look at this. Codeex just cited my own
paper. Isn't that funny?